in our series on the new normal we look
at how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our everyday lives now to
summer travel if you plan to travel this
summer you can expect major changes at
hotels including plexiglass barriers and
no more buffets say it ain't so States
lift restrictions hotel occupancy rates
are indeed inching up that's good news
Kris Van Cleave joins us now from inside
a JW Marriott hotel in Washington DC as
that hotel giant reopens about 300
locations this month again Chris that
sounds like progress good morning to you
good morning you know tell me the first
thing I was struck by is we walked into
a hotel for the first time in weeks its
just how quiet the lobby is listen
you're also going to notice these
barriers you talked about they are up to
create some distance and masks in many
places there a suggestion here in DC
masks are required this is the new
normal in hotels nationwide Marlon
Castro spends an extra 10 minutes in
each room at the Bethesda Maryland
Marriott cleaning starts with this
electrostatic fogger in its
hospital-grade disinfectant mist this is
a little bit of time consuming but we
want to make sure that every guys that
walks through the door
feels comfortable once the room is made
up and cleaned key touch points light
switches thermostat the remote control
are again wiped down with only about 11
percent occupancy at the hotel rooms
said empty for at least 48 hours we've
looked at every aspect of the operation
of a hotel
Marriott CEO Arne sørensen what's the
new normal the public space is going to
be less busy our associates wearing
masks yes that are more likely to want
to be in their room throw pillows and
magazines are gone from the rooms in
public spaces you'll see signs reminding
people to distance and Plexiglas
barriers at the check-in counter and at
the hotel bar this Marriott is testing a
UV sanitizer for room keys and
encouraging the use of an app based
digital key seating in the restaurant is
limited same goes for the pool and gone
for now is the buffet replaced by
individually packaged grab and go hotel
gyms are going to change too
the exercise bikes separated by
plexiglass if you want to get on an
elliptical or a treadmill watch the
signs because you can only use every
other machine we know that guests
believe quite reasonably that they can
control their interactions with people
in a hotel once you've gotten into your
guest room you are in your own space and
so the challenge for us is one we think
we can meet which is can we deliver a
room that the guests can have confidence
is clean this month Hilton is teaming
with the Mayo Clinic and lysyl to roll
out its clean stay which like Marriott
is focused on wiping down touch points
they'll mark cleaned rooms with these
stickers sealing the door sandals and
beaches resorts are also using the
foggers focusing on cleaning 18 common
touch points throughout the hotel and
using UV LED lights to inspect guest
rooms for cleanliness 64% of travelers
in a recent survey said improved
cleaning practices will significantly
impact their decision to stay at a hotel
whether you're an airline or a hotel you
are now building your brand on how well
you clean it's what people care about
right now cleanliness sanitation hygiene
these are rebuilding blocks for the
hotels as they rebuild confidence among
consumers to stay with them
people like Joseph Asafa who came from
LA to visit his mother did you have any
worry about staying at a hotel
no I didn't I would also assume that
people are not really coming to the
hotels or traveling as much and he's
right Marriott says bookings are down 70
to 75 percent but that the numbers are
improving week over week still the
company expects it'll be two to three
years before they see a complete
recovery back to 2019 levels and a lot
of that depends on how quickly people
feel comfortable traveling again and
being away from home Gail yeah Chris
it's gonna take a little bit to get used
to the quote new normal that we're all
going after experience I want to know
where we can get one of those little
foggers I'd like one of those babies
didn't walk around where today for you I
like that idea a lot yes could you
please I'd like it in yellow Thank You
Kris Van Cleave we got it staring
through there we got to put our toe in
the water thanks a lot Chris